rien
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne à les travaux de la
mission d'information du sénat sur le
médiator
jeudi à les sénateurs ont entendu daniel
havis de coqs et jean françois bergmann
respectivement président et
vice-président de la commission
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché de
l'afssaps
cette commission est au coeur de la
sphère du médiator c'est en effet elle
qui décide du sort des médicaments
depuis 1993 ses membres ont obligation
de déclarer leurs liens éventuels avec
lé laboratoire pharmaceutique
ils ne peuvent en effet être juge et
partie or c'est là que le bât blesse
l' affaire du médiator a en effet mis en
lumière de nombreux conflits d'intérêts
dont il a largement été question lors de
cette audition que je vous propose de
suivre à tout de suite bonne matinée a
tous bien mes chers collègues donc nous
poursuivons ces auditions avec monsieur
daniel vittecoq ici présents à droite
qui est donc président de la commission
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché de
l'afssaps et monsieur le professeur
jean-françois berman qui est vice
président de cette même commission
alors je vous rappelle messieurs les
professeurs que cette audition est
ouverte à la presse pour qu'il y ait pas
de malentendus a elle fait l'objet d'un
enregistrement en vue de sa diffusion
sur le site internet du sénat et
éventuellement un sur la chaîne public
sénat
je vous demanderais aussi puisque cette
audition est publique et en application
de l'article l 4113 tirs et 13 du code
de la santé publique de nous faire
connaître si vous en avez un mais
j'ai pu consulter sur le site de la sat
que vous en aviez vos liens avec des
entreprises produisant ou exploitants
des produits de santé ou les organismes
de conseil intervenant sur ces produits
chery cole peut-être et puis ensuite
monsieur berman s'est baladé gaston
publique d'intérêt et sur le site de
l'afssaps
oui oui j'ai des conflits d'intérêts au
titre de mon service en pendant ce
rallye des liens d'intérêts a des liens
d'intérêts ou y dansera pas de conflit
n'ont délivré aucun logo l'activité de
conseil alors le jeu sur la hat aller
chez que j'ai consultés gelé là je crois
vos liens d'intérêts enfin telles que
vous les avez déclarez vous allez dire
s'ils sont exacts puisque c'est une
déclaration que vous avez fait le 1er
octobre 2009
bon peut-être que pour lecture qui a une
déclaration plus récentes en tout cas
elle est pas rendu public
en tout cas cette époque vous déclariez
avec avoir des liens d'intérêt avec gsk
est effectivement tout le reste et en
anglais alors comme je ne pratique pas
l'anglais un donc je ne comprends pas ce
qui est marqué mais en tout cas gsk
comprend puisque c'est l'acronyme de de
glaxo smith kline qui est un laboratoire
bien connue donc à cette époque là vous
déclariez avoir des liens d'intérêt avec
ce laboratoire
aujourd'hui vous me dites que vous n'en
avez plus j'ai des liens d'intérêts oui
il tenu des études qui sont pratiqués
dans mon service gspc et magnin
factieuses dans un échec je nous donne
l'explication je suis pas besoin
d'explications on dit simplement vous
avez des liens où il avait passé j'ai
des liens n'ont pas déjà fication
est actualisée puisque j'actualise tous
les trois à six mois après chaque fois
qu'un élément nouveau il est actualisé
j'ai dû l'actualiser la dernière fois il
ya deux ou trois mois je crois à bron
alors ça ne figure pas sur le site de
l'afssaps à ce jeu c'est pas là vous
avez fait une déclaration qui ne figure
pas sur le site de l'absinthe
parce que la seule qui figure c'est
celle que vous avez fait le 1er octobre
et vous dites que vous en avez fait
depuis tous les membres des différentes
commissions et groupes de travail
doivent actualiser au moins une fois par
an et chaque fois qu'ils ont un lien à
l'intérêt nouveau donc ils le font mais
malheureusement il y avait quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne pas c'est c'est donc
au niveau de l'absence à ce moment là
oui c'est à dire que vos deux
générations ils ne sont pas transmises
si vous souhaitez je vous ferai parvenir
la déclaration actualisé pris le crois
doit dater à mon avis dia d'outreau -
oui et là vous n'avez plus on n'a plus
de lien on avait plus de liens
d'intérêts l'ag des études qui sont en
cours non mais vous avez des liens
d'intérêts oui il ya des intérêts qui se
font jeu mais qui n'ont pour lequel je
n'ai aucun intérêt personnel sont des
services des études qui sont faites dans
mon service
oui mais enfin vous savez bien qu'il ya
plusieurs types de liens d'intérêts
il y en a d'ailleurs on a divisé sa en
sept ou huit catégories
je crois qu il atteint ainsi le
particulier quand on travaille pour un
laboratoire ne mentionnez pas vers la
crème des liens d'intérêt conformément à
la hiérarchisation des liens qui était à
vie par l'afssaps je n'ai aucun lien
d'intérêt majeur avec les industriels
oui vous avez donc des bons alors je
retiens donc de votre déclaration que
celle que j'ai en ma possession n'est
pas la bonne que vous l'avez actualisé
et que malheureusement cette
actualisation ne figure pas sur le site
de l'afssaps
vous viendrez vous l'aurez demain par
d'accord monsieur le professeur berkman
à votre tour
alors j'ai aussi une des cages en
intérêts il est sur le site de l'afssaps
et déclarations de l'année antérieure
je pense que les déclarations 2010 ne
sont pas rendus publics
quittant que le rapport d'activités
afssaps 2010 n'a pas été publié donc il
est normal que vous n'ayez que les
déclarations datant de 2009
j'ai moi aussi actualiser ma déclaration
d'intérêts une quinzaine de jours et
vous ai amené pour information ce qui
nous a été distribué en début de
commissions die même la semaine dernière
c'est à dire les déclarations d'intérêts
de chacun des membres à la date de la
commission qui montre les liens
d'intérêts qualifiées de mineures dans
la hiérarchie du classement de l'afssaps
que j'ai avec certains laboratoires
donc ces documents elle existe et je
peux vous les laissez oui parce que je
vois là sur n'aurait déclaration est
faite le 11 décembre 2009 que vous avez
des liens donc avec aventis et vous
faites état de rémunération personnelle
cet aléa mineurs où il ya ces indiens
les arches hisser dans la hiérarchie
afssaps et un lien mineurs c'est un les
mineurs
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut pour aller un
majeur il faut avoir des parts d'un
départ il faut faire partie du conseil
d'administration faut faire partie
aborde un peu faire partie de ses
instances décisionnelles et concernant
ce lien avec sa fille rantissi
correspond un essai clinique qui
s'appelle laisser lifelock site news un
essai thérapeutique internationale
réalisée essentiellement mexique en
tunisie en chine et aux philippines chez
neuf mille malades qui compare les nox à
paris nos placebo dans la prévention de
la mortalité chez les malades
hospitalisés en médecine interne et un
essai thérapeutique pour lequel je me
suis battue pendant des années pour
qu'il voie le jour
je suis très fier de cet essai je suis
très fier de faire partie du 2 du comité
scientifique de cet essai qui vient de
finir et dont on aura les résultats en
août prochain lors du congrès de
pharmacologie à kyoto aussi
si les solutions permettre et ça me
permet de vous dire que ni l'afssaps ni
mon université paris diderot ni l'ap-hp
ne me paieront mon congrès à kyoto mais
ça à monsieur professeur jeu nous savons
que s'il n'y avait pas là du 5e congrès
très fier si ça c'est pas une
information
je suis donc très fier de cette étude et
je suis très fier de pouvoir grâce à
cette étude
faire connaître à la cokerie sur moi je
m'interroge les manceaux les autres
disciplines pour tenir des congrès et
comparé à bas les professeurs de
philosophie par exemple en sociologie on
peut pas faire appel au laboratoire
qu'est ce qui est ce qu'ils se trompent
cerises les congrès par exemple des
professeurs de physique on reste
sociologie les congrès de l il ya pas
les laboratoires la connaissance ne
finance pas céder mais comment font-ils
les éditeurs les éditeurs bien sûr un
mot oui ça j'aime pas penser les
laiteries qui ferait puis et puis les
budgets universitaires inclus peut être
mieux que dans nos disciplines des
possibilités de faire des voyages nous
si vous devez voyager ya qu'un seul
recours c'est le laboratoire
pharmaceutique je suis passé vient
d'annoncer pas les laboratoires c'est
senna qui vous paye
oui oui oui rationneront en hôpital ni
mon université
oui mais sans je sache je le comprends
bien mais je fais partie de 2,7 du sénat
et je ne fais pas partie d'autres choses
a normalement vous êtes vous êtes php eu
donc je verrais plutôt ce que ce soit
l'hôpital qui vous financez congrès je
dors ce serait là d'or est ce que vous
êtes quand même avoir d'être employé
d'industrie pharmaceutique s'être m
professeur de l'université et vous êtes
praticiens hospitaliers donc
de la même façon je suis sénateur donc
moi je vois pas d'inconvénient à ce que
ce soit le sénat qui financent mes
déplacements dans une façon je ne
verrais pas d'inconvénient à ce que ce
soit la l'université où l'hôpital qui
finance à vos congrès mais où
s'interroge c'est lorsque je constate
que ça n'est ni l'un ni l'autre qui
financent au corps m et les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
c'est de la même façon j'étais invité
récemment par une part avons pas gros
alimentaires a visité wii ou une la plus
grande fabrique de chocolat en europe à
la et même si je suis pas les figurez
vous parce que j'estimais que si je
voulais aller aller visiter ben j'en ai
qu'un le faire sur mes deniers ou
demander à ce que le sénat finances j'y
suis pas allé effectivement j'aurais pu
y aller je m'en suis un certain nombre
de collègues qui sont allés mais là il
ya effectivement conflit d'intérêt
voyez vous mais ça c'était c'est cécile
et de cet îlot de concessions c'est une
autre conception notre obligation spital
aux universitaires de faire de la
recherche
oui nous avons des points qui
s'appellerait ainsi gap pour une
publication qui font partie des
décisions de l'ap-hp et de l'université
pour les moyens les crédits qui sera
donc nous avons obligation obligation de
faire de la recherche
mais rob supplémentaires à l'intérieur
de l'hôpital par exemple
par exemple si vous faites pas de
recherche aujourd'hui dans chu bah vous
n'avez pas de deux dans la
classification cigap de vos points de
publications vous êtes en bas et ce
après et moi nous enfin je pense
nous aimerions tous que ce qu'ils nous
demandent de faire de la recherche
soient aussi ceux qui la finance mais
quand je leur parle de mon essai de
floch j'irai voir un ph ercis en disant
est ce que voulait financer les ses
livebox énoxaparine versus placebo en
mortalité
on me répondra non non non on n'a pas
d'argent mettre là-dedans c'est un
problème à voir avec sanofi aventis et
donc il ya effectivement une espèce de
situation schizophrénique nous sommes
obligés de faire de la recherche
mais on nous ne donne pas les moyens
financiers pour la faire ou pour la
présenter dans des congrès
internationaux
donc si le voyage à kyoto était payé par
l'ap-hp ou par de l'université denis
diderot parle à l'afssaps
je serais ravi d'y aller avec mieux
après comme il l'est pas je vais avec
sanofi aventis
oui mais je pense que il est pas il est
au contraire utile que là que vous
participiez à une recherche même si elle
est financée par sanofi aventis a
absolument aucun blâme mais où ça pose
problème c'est lorsque vous vous
retrouvez à la tête d'une commission
comme celle que dans vous êtes le
vice-président pour pour examiner des
médicaments qui sont produits par 1 à 10
et là il ya effectivement un problème et
je crois d'ailleurs que le règlement de
jeu les sous les yeux de la sape ça me
semble clair à est dit que le président
et le vice-président ne peuvent réaliser
de rapports d expertise sur les dossiers
soumis à l'évaluation de l'afssaps ne
peuvent avoir une activité régulière de
consultant pour le compte de ces
entreprises alors effectivement c'est
votre cas je le sais je le reconnais
mais il n'empêche que lorsque vous
examinez un médicament comme vous l'avez
fait comme vous le faites souvent
concernant paie l'hôtel laboratoire je
prends un exemple simple celui de sanofi
aventis puisque vous en avez parlé et
bien j'observe que malheureusement
lorsqu'on examine des médicaments
produits par aventis les 14 membres de
la commission des mêmes qui ont des
liens avec aventis ne quitte pas la
séance et ça effectivement
je le regrette personnellement parce que
là il ya malgré tout une violation de la
réglementation de l'afssaps et je peux
vous citer le cas auquel je fais
référence si vous souhaitez enfin vous
c'était une réunion de septembre h et
j'ai pris ça au hasard mais il ya
beaucoup d'autres rang
il ya l'art effectivement il ya un
véritable problème
en tout cas je peux vous témoigner que
chaque fois qu'un dossier de sanofi en
garde à vue chaque je peux vous
témoigner que chaque fois qu'ils aient
un dossier sanofi aventis qui est
discuté en commission d'amm est même
jean-françois n'est pas dans la salon
pour vous vous quitter moi je n'ai pas
de lien dao irait mal et vous vous
quitter oui absolument
alors écoutez il ya quand même là
quelque chose qui me qui m'a un petit
peu surpris âgées j'ai sous les yeux la
réunion de septembre 2010 à septembre
2010 je vais la retrouver
voilà une commission da et même qui a eu
lieu le 9 septembre 2010 vous avez donc
examiner alors je sais bien vous allez
examiner très rapidement en tout cas
vous examiner un certain nombre de
médicaments daf qui sont donc fabriqué
par aventis il y avait le lovenox
il y avait d'autres le maalox par
exemple etc etc
et lorsque vous avez examiner ces
médicaments tous les membres de la
commission sont restés présents 1
le seul qui ait quitté la salle c'est
monsieur jean jé claude lorsqu'on a
examiné un médicament
le bufexamac est là il est sorti parce
qu'il avait effectivement des liens
d'intérêt avec le laboratoire qui le
fabrique
l'accusation que qu'est que vous que
vous posez jeunes entendus je vous
demande de me croire c'est le point du
secrétariat la commission des mêmes qui
depuis quelques
moi a fait des progrès et à la limite je
remercierai hélas même si c'est un peu
triste
le problématique du médiator au jour
d'aujourd'hui nous avons vous avez même
sur le site
le verbatim complet des commissions des
mêmes à ce que les comptes rendus ne
font pas état ne faisait pas à cette
époque là et pas systématiquement des
gens qui entrent et outils sortez donc
au jour d'aujourd'hui les choses sont
plus claires et vous allez le voir en
tout cas à travers les verbatim bon en
tout cas vous reconnaissez que le 9
septembre 2010 la réglementation n'a pas
été respecté je crois que je me reproche
pas vous le dire comme ça vous prennent
au dépourvu mais pas de le dire comme ça
bon je pense qu'il faut revenir
donc là je vous ai amené par exemple qui
a été présenté en dernière séance ou
pour chacun des membres il ya conflit
d'intérêts 012 selon qu'ils soient
mineurs ou majeurs tout ce qu un conflit
majeur numéro 2 sont avertis avant la
séance par david morel de du fait qu'ils
devront quitter
il faut dire aussi que si très
franchement la discussion qu'il a eue
sur le maroc sur produits ou carrément
moi j'ai jamais allant participer
consiste à modifier une phrase dans la
monographie sur l'utilisation du maroc
chez la femme enceinte
quand on voit le programme que j'ai
amené aussi programme de la commission
des ae même de la dernière fois qui fait
à lui seul neuf pages avec jeux pas 90
ou 100 produits qui vont être discutés
dont certains produits qui vont aller
discuter en groupe c'est qu'on va
discuter par exemple d'un problème avec
les antitussifs ben il ya douze labos
qui ont des antitussifs et si on va
jusqu'au bout du raisonnement non
seulement il faudrait sortir quand il ya
un produit sanofi aventis mais quand il
ya un produit d'un laboratoire
concurrentes sanofi-aventis ouais donc à
ce moment là il sort tout le temps alors
je pense justement que ce que ce que
vous dites ça ne condamne pas finalement
la proposition actuelle de la commission
est à dire que si on appliquait ce
règlement ça reviendrait à bloquer le
fonctionnement de la commission
donc est-ce qu'il faut pas justement
envisager une autre organisation c'est à
dire d'accepter tout simplement que les
membres de cette commission n'est pas de
liens d'intérêts avec les laboratoires
c'est quelque chose qui me semblerait
beaucoup plus simple il n'aurait plus
besoin de sortir on pourrait fonctionner
de façon harmonieuse et parce que vous
venez de témoigner que avec le règlement
actuel on peut pas fonctionner quoi donc
il va falloir choisir ou bien on modifie
dingue loi en disant bombe a coûté tant
pis aller à d'intérêt c'est d'appeler
c'est incontournable c'est absolument
indispensable donc on ferme les yeux et
vous continuer à fonctionner comme ça ou
alors on est plus exigeant et votre
commission peut plus fonctionner donc il
faut effectivement je pense que en
changer les règles ça me paraît tout à
fait alors il ya une autre question
voudrais vous poser concernant la
participation de l'industrie
pharmaceutique parce que j'ai appris à
mon grand nez à la grande surprise je
savais donc que que l'industrie
pharmaceutique était représentée en tant
que telle à la commission nationale de
pharmaco vigilance et la commission de
la transparence mais je ne savais pas
qu'elle était présente à toutes les
commissions d'un même corps gelé après
incidemment par la lettre que adressé
oleme madame marthely lucky
ni plus ni moins indiquer aux votants
faras jeudi qu' elle allait enfin enfin
appliquer la réglementation ce qui veut
dire que jusque là comme vous dites
thaler jusqu'à 7 ce drame du médiator on
ne respectait pas la réglementation
alors ça vaut posait pas de problème ça
vous poser un problème le oui absolument
le lem n'en reviens pas entendu les lier
aux différents directeurs généraux et
j'ai d'ailleurs je vous entends pas bien
mais en même temps oui je les dis aux
différents goûts différents directeurs
généraux le lem est invité ne fait pas
partie de la commission avait même était
invité permanent invité permanent
oui lorsque
oui invité permanent j'ai compris que
c'était le statut c'était le statut mais
un statut mais l'aca reposer sur quoi
sympa c'est ce que j'ai effectivement
éplucher le règlement intérieur de la
commission de mise sur le marché jamais
dit que que le lait mais et un est un
est invité pour mano je jouais même que
la participation et à l'article 4 cette
participation aux réunions de personnes
non membres de la commission il est bien
évident que que exceptionnellement
exceptionnellement des personnes
extérieures à l'afssaps notamment et
stagiaires pourront assister en nombre
restreint à une séance de la commission
avec l'accord préalable du directeur de
la direction de l'émanation là des
maires et du président de la commission
il sera fait état de la présence de ces
personnes en début de séance afin de
s'assurer qu'elle ne suscite pas
l'objection d'objections de la part des
membres de la commission ces personnes
signent un engagement de confidentialité
avant la séance donc cet article n'est
absolument pas respectée donc là là
l'industrie pharmaceutique
et quand le rapport de l'igas se dit
qu'il y avait une coproduction entre
l'industrie et les haies et les experts
je pense qu'elle ne fait que traduire
cette réalité donc c'est profondément
regrettable je pense que si on veut
restaurer la confiance dans la
population
il va falloir mettre un terme à ces
pratiques d'ailleurs madame la diane
la directrice adjointe avait bien
compris puisqu'elle a été obligé de vous
rappeler à l'ordre
puisque vous n'étiez pas capable en tant
que président de la commission de faire
respecter la réglementation et ça c'est
profondément regrettable
la présence du lem était le fait de la
direction général de l'afssaps ou moi
quand j'ai pris la présidence de la
commission en 2003 le directeur à
l'époque était monsieur duneton je lui
avait signifié que j'ai été interpellé
par la présence du lem à la commission
met donc c'est alors pas écouté jose
alors c'est fini et donc on m'a fait
comprendre que c'était souhaitable parce
que ça facilite les rapports
j'en ai discuté y compris avec monsieur
marc imbert aussi il se trouve que ces
temps derniers le lem n'est plus invité
permanent donc monsieur morin à qui est
d'accord pour que le lem ne soit pas
présent voilà je vous rapporte à fait
comment voulez vous qu'un président hu à
moisson à dire dire je démissionne parce
que le lait mais là c'est pas une source
de contamination à ce point là à mon
avis quand même mes jeux et j'ai obtenu
que le lem sortent chaque fois que nous
lui demandons sortir il sortait beaucoup
plus souvent ces femmes puissent garder
souvent de sortir alors oui mais c'est
pas marqué dans les pv mais je peux vous
le dire et jean-françois oui ça vous
aurait pu la peine de le marquer
désormais dans les pv puisque il n'aura
plus la peine de sortir puisque il ne
sera pas en très bon d'accord j'ai
compris que la présence du lem de ce qui
m'a été expliqué c'est que sa facilité
dix ans les rapports les comptes rendus
de réunion pour les piques aux
industriels plus facilement ce que oui
mais elle n'aurait pas pu décoder dans
nos comptes rendus nous avoue oui et
vous avez cette explication vous a
convaincu
we can oui chez bergman vous voulez
peut-être privé non je sens un peu de
2,2 sous-entendu damgan vos questions
moi qui sont ces sous-entendus aux seuls
professionnels on est pourri on est nul
on est mauvais renée acheté en est vendu
et que je regarderai bien que je me
garderai bien de faire ça a simplement
j'observe que ça fait d'être ressenti et
il est d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on aille
lui dans la presse ou dans certains
rapports et c'est vrai que femme je
voudrais pas souvent 90 ans il conserve
y un an pas absolument pas je vous
remercie
d'autres élus mais ce que je te jure ce
que je devrais expliquer d'abord
promenant sur le lem
moi je les vois de plus longtemps ils
sont je possède vrai que là ou pas sont
de braves gens si je les connaissais je
suis comme vous sont très sympathiques
et rien ni interviennent jamais dans les
débats et les seules interventions dont
je me souvienne concernant les
représente de l'homme dulayme
correspondait essentiellement à des
points assez réglementaire de deux
décisions prises sur un dossier sur sa
jamais été sur le fond des décisions
mais c'était souvent une des
interventions pour rôle pour faciliter
les démarches purement réglementaire
sétois obligé de me mais c'est ce que
justifiée aux yeux des menus à l'idée
par exemple d'inviter des représentants
d'associations de patients par exemple
que ça vous est arrivé ça vous est
arrivé au point niveau de la commission
d'amm est même énormes et n'ont ils pas
rater puisque je te demande pas qu'il
soit invité permanent non mais
simplement comme ça pour dire tiens
puisque les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
sont là il fabrique le médicament qui
serait intéressant d'avoir aussi ce
qu'il est
qu'ils aient confiance en tout cas de
mon fait personnelle un artisan de la
relation entre les patients et les
agences sanitaires dans le domaine du
vih depuis la création de l' agence du
médicament les les associations de
patients sont reçus très régulièrement
et au courant des dossiers des émissions
et mérimée gpg pour j'ai toujours dit
que je souhaitais
j'ai toujours dit que je souhaitais il
semble que ce soit pour le mans
réalisable s'est rapidement et je le
souhaite que sur des sujets sensibles et
difficile les patients puissent être
entendus il ya des sujets sensibles et
complexes et ça me paraît logique que
les patients puissent être entendus et
est donc encore un petit peu le poule a
le pouvoir d'influencé que vous voulez
nous conférer n'est vraiment pas à la
hauteur malgré tout de ce que moi je
pense que je veux pas vous vous pour
conférer avouables ou simplement je vous
reproche de ne pas avoir appliqué la
réglementation c'est tout bon les
complexes c'est vrai doivent expliquer
que si on l'appliqué on pourrait plus
fonctionner c'est vrai ce qui va donc
nous inciter nous a proposé des réformes
bien entendu mais c'est tout ce que je
veux c'est tout ce que je veux vous
faire dire est ce que je vais essayer de
comprendre c'est tout mais il n'est pas
question de mettre en doute mon
intégrité vos s'il en est pas question
mais simplement il ya une réglementation
elle s'applique à tout le monde en vous
ne le respectez pas permettez moi moi en
tant que sénateur je suis là aussi pour
contrôler le fonctionnement
d'institutions comme ça mais je constate
que ça fonctionne pas bien
faudrait juste souligner deux points
c'est vraiment une personne qui a
toujours été proche et qui a toujours
soutenu des associations patience est
vraiment daniel vittecoq
non mais mais ok dans le domaine du vih
et et je peux témoigner que dans les
discussions que nous avons en
particulier pour les médicaments
sensibles ou les associations de
patients sont importantes les maladies
rares les meilleurs fallin le vih daniel
vittecoq a toujours voulu exprimer
prendre la position des des patients le
deuxième point concerne notre notre
fonction au sein de l'afssaps
je vous rappelle que nous sommes
bénévoles que nous fait nous faisons
soit rien combien êtes vous rémunérez
tient 08 intéressant 0 faut le dire
nous sommes bénévoles nous faisons ça
parce qu'on a forcément un peu problème
je suis d'accord une certaine foi dans
l'évaluation c'est moi j'ai été vice
présent la commission de la transparence
pendant un certain nombre d'années
maintenant je suis friand de la mmg été
rapporteur ça fait 20 ans que je fais ça
bénévolement
pourquoi croyez vous qu'on le con qu'on
va le jeudi matin à 8h30 au carrefour
pleyel avec 900 pages de dossiers qu'on
a lu pendant le week-end précédent vous
croyez que cc c'est parce qu'on y croit
je croyais je crois rien je vous voulez
vous qu'on observe c'est pas pour gagner
des sous puisqu'on n'en gagne pas c'est
pas pour gagner de la nasa
donc c'est qu'on arrive parfois en
l'évaluation est en omission et quand on
fait ça encore plus en plus de notre
fonction de médecins d'enseignants on ne
peut pas aussi vérifier le règlement de
la fsa fait vérifier que chaque article
du code de procédure interne de la fab
soit soir soit respectée on vient là en
plus de notre temps de travail hospitalo
universitaire parce qu'on pense que
c'est un patient de lui sucer sur le
comparer c'est en plus poussée sur le
temps de travail c'est sur le jeudi
matin
mais le dimanche quand on lit les 900
pages en plus et si on les assure et en
plus sur un an + et ça fait partie de ce
qu'on appelle les migac en principe qui
devrait permettre de retour de notre
investissement pour la communauté mais
c'est vrai que ont fait ça parce qu'on y
croit parce que c'est important que en
particulier dans le domaine de
l'infectiologie la france puisse faire
entendre sa position au niveau des
années même européenne par exemple mais
on n'est pas non plus tenu de vérifier
la totalité des missions de la structure
de la commission de pharmacovigilance
doit-on agen
je parlais de la réglementation de la
commission d'un immeuble qu'elle
n'appartenait je ne sais pas bien sûr je
ne vais pas vous vous demander des
comptes sur la commission d'un coup j ai
bien entendu madame blandin vous avez
demandé la parole vous avez donné
beaucoup de réponses que j'attendais
donc le lem étaient présents il était
quelquefois sortant à votre demande
il n'était pas complètement muet mais
vous dites que c'est sur des
interventions ciblées ya des précisions
que j'aimerais avoir en plus combien de
personnes à représentants ou plusieurs
du lem et quelle personne est ce que les
présents étaient adaptés à l'ordre du
jour de ce qu'elle est débattue ou
est-ce que c'était toujours le même
représentant
il y avait deux repris il y avait deux
représentants du lait qui était toujours
les mêmes toujours je confirme ce que
c'est a dit jean-françois il
n'intervenait jamais sur le fond des
dossiers
c'est uniquement sur les aspects disons
réglementaires ou deux il intervenait
quand même paris demandé la parole pour
refuser la parole appartient aux oraux y
sont là j'estime que ça va de soi mais
quand il y avait un problème ils ont des
kits et industriels qui pouvait se poser
et qu'à la limite le lem pouvait donner
des informations puisque c'est un
syndicat
un autre industriel donc dans ces cas là
j'en redemande et sortir ce qu'il n'a
jamais pris moins de problèmes
monsieur ben je voulais une petite
précision lorsque les décisions
commandes sont prises les décisions
d'une manière pratique dans le cas de
votre commission dont une délibération
le monde intervient au moment de la
décision c'est un vote à main levée
secret bon ça se passe dans la pratique
comment se déroule une réunion d'examen
d'une demande de m
voilà et les mouvements le comme dit
jean françois les 900 pages et les neuf
pages d'ordre du jour sont de toute
façon déjà prédit gérés par les groupes
de travail
sinon vous imaginez pas quand mais
globalement on allait les rapports des
groupes de travail et où il ya
globalement un double rapport qui est
celui des évaluateurs internes et de
l'expertisé externe avec le président du
groupe de travail qui aboutit à une
décision qui le plus souvent et
consensuelle est assez facile à prendre
et donc celles à la recherche du
consensus
le vote se fait à main levée sauf sur
les sujets sensibles et sur des sujets
sensibles à ce qu'on en fait un vote se
fait un mal vu sous les yeux du du
représentant de l'industrie
pharmaceutique bien entendu s'il était
resté là bas s'il est là oui oui et
comme il est la rue donc ça se fait sous
les yeux oui mais comme de toute façon
ces cas là il est pas d'essence et
décision d'interdire il suffit deviendra
ensuite directeur de général de savoir
s'il suit la décision de femmes comme
elle sera publics de sas en tout le
monde aux orateurs j'ai sur le fond
c'est pas est ce que c'est ce que s'est
posée la question quelquefois de d'avoir
un vote secret ou est-ce que celui des
quais des questions que vous vous posez
entre vous à l'intérieur de la
commission le vote et kaba je demande
aux collègues s'ils souhaitent voter à
main levée ou sur les sujets sensibles
nous votons à part écrit il ya des
bulletins qui avec la question posée
pour contre marquez titulaire suppléant
puisque donc il ya qu un seul vote
c'est soit le titulaire soit son
suppléant situé en est pas là et donc il
ya qu une seule
il faut que nous ayons quorum pour que
le vote bien traduit soit acceptée
systématiquement
si quelqu'un veut le vote à bulletin
secret oui je la vends chabot nous le
demander oui non seulement est ce que
est ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
finalement aussi pour quelle raison il
est plus facile d'obtenir une à mêmes
puisque seulement 5 % seulement des
demandes sont rejetées que de suspendre
ou de retirer un médicament
pourquoi il est difficile de retirer
n'est même c'est ça votre question en
fait ça je peux vous dire que j'en fais
le constat pense que jean-françois
dirais la même chose c'est certainement
c'est difficile de retirer huit ans et
théoriquement c'est la douleur et c'est
notre douleur croyez bien pour une
raison simple c'est que derrière il ya
des contentieux sont en permanence
sujet discussions de hélas plus
difficile de nos épreuves que nous en
russe et en dernier c'est le ketum quand
même pour lequel le conseil d'état a
cessé quand même le sol depuis de
nombreuses années un c'est quand même
pas le seul produit qui a été retiré du
marché
il y en a eu beaucoup d'autres médias
vraiment bien avant dire je sais sur un
objet de contentieux a été remis sur le
marché suit un contention conseil dit
oui dans le sahel
oui mais c'est l'exception qui confirme
la règle enfin pour répondre à votre
question effectivement disons le les
contentieux avec les malades et moi
c'est ce qui m'obsède beaucoup parce que
bien entendu on est là pour les malades
on est là pour les malades jean-françois
la dit quand même c'est pas notre coeur
de métier on fait ça en plus
mais ce qu'on veut c'est que le bien et
le dossier du médiator est une grande
douleur pour des gens qui veulent faire
le bien et ce qui l'est beaucoup plus
disons fréquent d'avoir des contentieux
avec l'industrie qui a ses avocats pour
redresser les choses et donc les lélés
la menace du contentieux wii est une
menace qui fréquentent souvent perçu
c'est pour ça que c'est difficile
si le dossier si disons le dossier du
robusta suffisante bien entendu c'est
facile à prendre et je pense que plus le
système sera transparent plus ce sera
facile de prendre des décisions mais sur
les sujets qui sont à la marge
la crainte du contentieux réel oui alors
il nous est rappelé elle nous avaler
monsieur le professeur perlman faudra
intervenir
c'est une question difficile est une
question cruciale et je pense que pour
ce qui est de vous disiez ce facile de
mettre sur le marché
faut bien différencier deux périodes la
période des années 70 80 90 la période
du médiator par exemple qui était déjà
et même nationale oui c'est ce qui nous
l'a finalement ça a été facile jusqu'aux
années 80 puisque les dossiers et et la
méthodologie n'était pas bonne
ça a été très dur dans les années 80-90
parce que là il ya eu
une vraie réglementation et niveau
d'exigence nationale il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les a et même européennes
sont paradoxalement plus facile à
obtenir au niveau européen qu'elle
n'était au niveau national il y a
quelques années pour une raison assez
simple c'est que c'est un vote à la
majorité qui se fait par les 27 pays de
la communauté européenne
les 6-14 pays disent oui c'est oui pour
les 27
même si la france dit non et
actuellement le le niveau d'exigence
d'une a et même européenne est plutôt
plus bas que celle que telle exigence de
la même france 10 à 10 ou 15 ans pour
des raisons multiples c'est une décision
assez économique
ces décisions qui se fait à la majorité
et puis surtout il ya beaucoup de pays
qui n'ont pas la même image de là mêmes
que la france et qui considèrent que la
même c'est simplement une étape purement
administrative
les hollandais par exemple dit souvent
oui ou médicaments parce qu'ils savent
très bien que les médecins landais très
raisonnable une fois que le produit en
lui-même comme à ce que les médecins
français sont pas raisonnables non non
bien évidemment par rapport au médecin
hollandais les médecins français ne sont
pas raisonnables c'est à dire qu'il
croit qu'une autorisation à mêmes est
une recommandation et il grimpe au
nouveau produit alors que les médecins
hollandais sont beaucoup plus
raisonnables
de même toute une série de pays de l'est
donne toujours oui à la mêmes pour ne
pas donner l'impression qu'ils sont en
retard en termes de progrès
technologique
sachant très bien qu'en aval ne pourront
pas rembourser ou peut se payer les
médicaments dont il suffit que 14 pays
disent oui pour que le médicament
viennent sur le marché donc il est
facile d'avoir une à mm aujourd'hui en
revanche pour enlever une à mêmes il ya
le problème des contentieux mais il ya
aussi le problème de de l'obligation que
nous avons pour décider qu'aujourd'hui
on veut retirer une année même d'avoir
des événements nouveaux alors comment on
peut avoir des événements nouveaux soit
des données supplémentaires d'efficacité
qui sont décevantes par rapport à ce
qu'on savait auparavant de l'efficacité
du médicament soit des données nouvelles
de sécurité qui montrent qu'il ya des
effets indésirables nouveau
connaissais pas avant bon alors donnée
supérieure nouvelle d'efficacité très
bien quand on les a vous vous doutez
bien qu'un médicament qui est sur le
marché depuis 30 ans et pour lequel on
est assez douteux de l'efficacité ne va
pas se précipiter pour faire une étude
nouvelle pour montrer que finalement il
n'est pas si bon que ça un faux-pas faut
pas rêver et comme nous n'avons pas ce
qui avait été dit notamment avec
l'auditeur précédent de moyens de faire
de la recherche unique hors de
l'industrie
eh ben on n'a pas de vrai bâton pour
pousser d'industrie affaires cssd fiq
est donc si vous aviez ses moyens ce
serait une arme que qu'il a pour être
utilisé à condition que condition que
cette arme soit usées utilisées
intelligemment il c'est à dire parce que
je vous fais confiance
demandez à tous les médicaments je ne
ferai confiance et sous tendent leur
efficacité
il ya un problème de priorisation qui
est très difficile le deuxième point
c'est d'avoir des données nouvelles de
pharmacovigilance qui permettent de se
dire ah bah tiens il ya quelque chose
qu'on ne connaissait pas il ya dix ans
et là c'est sûr que quand on l'a on s'en
sert et c'était les bacs et avec keita
mais c'est le débat qu'on a tout le
temps pour essayer de retirer une mm
pour un produit que nous nous jugeons
suspect encore faut-il que les données
de pharmacovigilance soit enrichi et et
si le système de pharmacovigilance nouri
chip hâlé de débat on est on est coincé
on ne peut rien faire ou bien il
faudrait qu'à ce moment là on puisse
avoir une façon de différencier un
médicament par rapport aux autres de de
la casse dans les statines il ya une
statine qui a plongé il ya quelques
années parce qu'elle donnait plus
d'effet musculaire que toxiques que les
autocars tient ainsi à la cérivastatine
saison mais ça il fallait qu'on ait les
données comparatives qui montrait qu
effectivement avait plus avec elle
qu'avec la pravastatine la saint vaast à
ty et ça c'est difficile quand on a un
système de recueil des effets
indésirables aussi poreux que celui
qu'on a actuellement et aussi avec un
tel niveau de sous déclaration ou deux
pas de déclarations du tout quand il
s'agit de valvulopathie cinq ans après
la prise d'un médicament par exemple eh
bien on a pas les be
malheureusement pour aller jusqu'au bout
de notre démonstration et ça si on les
avait on le ferait vous pouvez nous
rappeler les conditions dans lesquelles
la décision initiale des mêmes a été
obtenu pour prendre un exemple concret
par les laboratoires servier pour la
commercialisation du médiator
est ce que 78 des jeudis pas le désert
mais pas loin
la brousse ça me parait accepter qu'on
était encore un peu petit quand même
question
non mais ce qu'a dit jean françois sur
les éléments nouveaux je trouve
parce que somme toute on est quand même
là pour médiator donc je pense qu'il
faut aussi qu'on en parle quand même
ah oui oui pour mais il nous reste
encore du temps monsieur le président
rassurez vous mais pousse vers le haut
pour faire le lien
maison avec ce que dit jean françois
bergmann sur les éléments nouveaux et
les difficultés des études post post mm
elles ont été demandés quand même elle
n'était pas notre faveur je suis en 2000
qu'elles ont été demandés en 2000 il a
été demandé des études pour clarifier
quand même la place du médicament dans
le diabète et le risque de valvulopathie
et un gay parce que c'était la source
longues études elles ont été commencée
tardivement elles ont été commencées
fortin dit mens pour donner leurs
résultats en 2009 qui ont confirmé
effectivement les données même frachon
il aimait mai
l'elysée ces prêts à les laisser ces
prêts à mêmes sont quelquefois moins
long bien sûr mais il lui revient sûr
mais si nous avions eu si nous avions eu
des possibilités encore une fois
peut-être qu'on nous donnait le pouvoir
d' influence qui est plus important que
ce que vous croyez on aimerait bien la
voir s'il y avait pu y avoir un peu hrc
par exemple sur le risque de
valvulopathie en enclenchée en 2000 avec
une participation de servier je ne sais
pas peu importe mais sur le fond si on
pouvait avoir cette exigence
cette étude qui était demandée en 2000
elle a commencé en 2001 très laid à
savoir puiser l'eau si vous rajoutez
ensuite ils sont pas suffisamment
nombreux
enfin je sais pas super hrc mais là vous
savez jamais à percer là dessus et si au
moins six au moins cette triste épreuve
peut déboucher sur le fait que et c'est
pas nouveau à ce qu'on sait déjà
rencontrées pour d'autres sujets oui il
faudrait que ça avance il faudrait que
ça avance parce que les experts pour
être responsable de tout suis l'est
n'est pas responsable du fonctionnement
interne de l'afssaps pour aider on n'est
là que pour aider
non mais le responsable a démissionné je
vous signale un bon après il ya une
structure et et deuxièmement et
deuxièmement les industriels doivent
faire leur travail
et troisièmement et ils le font très
très bien en ce qui me concerne sur ce
que je suis admiratif sur dossier est ce
que c'est que de en face ce soit moins
efficace
je suis admiratif devant le
professionnalisme des industriels du
médicament ça en tout cas je ne suis pas
je ne sais pas si vous faites de
l'humour ou pas mais je ne suis je
souhaiterais cv non je fais 2 je parle
sérieusement je pense qu'elle est très
bon et je viens et je voudrais pouvoir
dire la même chose de des autorités de
santé
malheureusement je ne peux pas il
faudrait admiratif de la façon je suis
admiratif pour le professionnalisme de
la durée pharmaceutique je voudrais être
admiratif face au professionnalisme des
autorités de santé
or je m'aperçois que ça n'est pas le cas
voilà reconnaissez que si vous êtes
admirative industries pharmaceutiques
aux laboratoires à qui on demande de
faire une étude
10 mans avec les conséquences que ça
peut avoir je ne suis pas
personnellement admiratif lâché dire ça
l'autre élément c'est si le corps
médical et la sélection après une très
globale de pédagogie aussi peut-être
universitaire la place qui est faite à
la pharmacovigilance anciennement est
drôlement trop orphelines et si les
médecins quand même avait plus tendance
à déclarer les événements indésirables
les signaux d'alert le système sera un
peu différente et il est obligé de faire
avec notre douleur et c'est notre
douleur on est bien obligé de constater
quand même que les les les laboratoires
sont quand même très très fort le
laboratoire servier a réussi à maintenir
pendant trente ans sur le marché un
médicament qui servait à rien qui en
plus étaient toxiques et face à cette
situation les autorités sanitaires n'ont
absolument rien pu faire et je sais vous
le reconnaissez pas mais il a fallu
l'intervention d'irène frachon pour qu'
on en arrive finalement à la suspension
de ce médicament mais je sais que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord puisque je les lui a
dans les différents mails d'adressés etc
vous pensiez que ça n'était pas du tout
irène frachon qui est en quoi que ce
soit a mené la suspension le retrait de
ce médicament
c'était l'étude regulate plus en étude
si je suis écouté j'ai lu dans tout ça
c'est ce que vous avez monsieur vous
avez face à vous le rédacteur de ce mail
donc à la limite je veux m'expliquer
vous avez le rédacteur du mail pour une
fois vous m'avez en fasse plus je peux
m'exprimer sur le match du bon bout
on peut bien sûr semaines et mois c'est
ce que j'ai eu oui d'abord circulé on
n'est pas public c'est un document qui
est interne à l'ensemble de nos
collègues ne voulait comme adressé à à
la chargée des relations eric de servir
comme un but j'ai répondu quand même
j'ai fait vous savez je pense que vous
avez un ordinateur donc c'est quand vous
faites répondre à tous c'est d'ailleurs
c'est quelque chose que je dis comment
quand vous faites quand vous cliquez sur
répondre à tous vous avez la liste de
tous les gens avec qui vous avez
répondu c'est comme elle avait commencé
à conan si c'est pas n'importe qui c'est
la personne qui est chargé des relations
publiques du laboratoire servier
alors peut-être c'est l'échappée mais
enfin c'est quand même celle épouse jean
roger claude donc le pour moi dans la
liste c'était genre je joue alors je ne
savais pas bon alors là vous m'apprenez
quelque chose savaient pas que la clause
nomme d'ailleurs ça n'apporte peut hein
je connaissais vraiment si je connais
pas monsieur claude c'est aussi vous me
laissez pas ce que c'était son épouse
que vous lui avait envoyé le mais je
comprends pas très bien la ce
allez-y continuer quand ils ont laissé
m'exprimer quand même oui oui monsieur
mais l'a été parce que vous savez pour
être espère-t-on même pas être expert on
n'en est pas moins des hommes quand même
et de temps en temps on a quand même
certaines douleurs la douleur elle
venait surtout et c'était donc vous avez
le mail initial qui était le mail de
michel diaz kate a démandé commission
des mêmes au moment de la sortie du
livre d'irène frachon et c'était pas
tellement une critique d'ailleurs du
livre d'irène frachon est certainement
pas dans mon esprit d'ailleurs gelé mis
dans le mail est critique d'irène
frachon protéger l'admiration
je le dire je le dis au sénat jeudi au
sénat oui devant vous j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour cette personne qui
grâce à son obstination a permis de
faire décelé un problème pour lequel
tout le système est passé à côté le
laboratoire en premier effectivement le
corps médical tous les cardiologues tous
les chirurgiens cardiaques
tous les chirurgiens cardiaques qui ont
remplacé des valves à des patients que
rossi médiator avec un aspect assez
spécifique quand même et qui n'ont pas
noté que s'il y avait quelque chose qui
se passait et une alerte qui pouvaient
comment voulez vous que nous experts et
convié vous que les chirurgiens
cardiaques puisse faire le rapprochement
jamais à aucun moment dans la vie parmi
les effets indésirables une le risque de
hyper tension atteint le pioneer ou le
risque de valvulopathie jamais en trente
ans jamais mais alors comment voulez
vous que ça j'y reviens sur comment
voulez vous qu'un chirurgien puisse
établir de lui-même un lien entre une
gageure
je vous postez un disque qui ne figure
même pas sur le rcp puis je vous posais
habana sociaux simoneau d'ailleurs a été
complètement étonné quand on lui a parlé
de de cette relation parce que il était
loin de penser qu'on puisse y puisse y
avoir mais c'est pourtant le pâtis c'est
pour ça que le drame de médiator et le
drame aussi le prêt d'un système de
santé sur le fond je ne sais pas si vous
êtes médecin je l'étais dans la jeunesse
mais moi je ne je cumule pas si vous
voulez jeu quand je suis de bus et d'atr
chez cessé d'exercer ce que l'on sait au
jour d'aujourd'hui se connaissaient au
jour d'aujourd'hui c'est classe mais des
valvulopathies associé au médiator est
un aspect très spécifique c'est-à-dire
que quand on remplace une valve quand on
remplace une vague de quelqu'un qui a
reçu du médiator elle a un aspect est
disons bourgeonnant qui n'a rien à voir
avec la valvulopathie habituel je ne
critique pas et je suis pas là pour non
plus accuser qui que ce soit mais je
fais un constat simplement je fais un
constat que les chirurgiens cardiaques
ont remplacé des valves sans se rendre
compte qu'elle avait un aspect atypique
je ne demande pas forcément inscrit un
lien qui soit fait avec le médiator
parce que là il faut déjà la subtilité
mais au moins que la communauté
cardiaque le 10 ou d'un coup tiens c'est
pas le retour du rhumatisme articulaire
aigu qu'arrive ya quelque chose qui se
passe n'est pas normal si on a une
système de santé qui fonctionne bien à
l'achat est sous toutes les systèmes de
dison de d'articulation notre système on
devait percevoir un phénomène pour
lequel ensuite effectivement il y avait
le lien à faire du médiateur qui est
autre chose donc au jour d'aujourd'hui
tout est simple tout est clair ça
n'était pas clair ça n'était pas clair à
l'époque comme vous l'avez dit
effectivement donc ce double aspect à la
fois des études fait tardivement pour
lequel les évaluateurs et le système de
santé a demandé quand même malgré tout
en 2000 que des études soient faites
est ce que nous craignons quelque chose
peut pas accepter l'idée qu'on dise que
nous ne craignons rien qu'on a rien fait
des études ont été demandées elles ont
été faits tardivement effectivement et
alain frachon heureusement a pas permis
d c'est ce phénomène est peut-être
intervenir plus tôt plus tôt j'ai
presque envie dire c'est dommage que
l'effet trop tardivement je rends
hommage
je rends hommage donc oublions personne
n'est parfait
oui mais une fois bref je rends hommage
à son travail et c'est une des pistes
sur lequel effectivement vous politique
va falloir peut-être que vous agissiez
aussi sur comment on peut articuler nos
différents systèmes comme en particulier
le pm ainsi c'est ce qu'elle a fait il
est parti comme en super g vous dire que
moi j'ai un lien un lien et ciment
intellectuelle avec madame ration c'est
qu'au même moment où elle faisait son
étude moi j'ai fait une étude dans mon
établissement sur le pml si la tolérance
des anticancéreux par exemple il ya une
série de cancérologie qui est assez
important dans l'établissement pour
essayer de voir globalement si les
effets secondaires qu'on observait sont
les mêmes que l'on a dans le lait les
rcp de nos produits sur le fond n'a pas
trouvé grand chose
un frachon elle a mis dans le mille
effectivement elle a découvert le lien
qui avait entre valvulopathie et donc en
tout cas moi je remercie donc on doit on
doit rendre hommage à son travail
en fait j'en prends acte je dois quand
même vous signaler que vous avez pas les
insurgés qu'avec mais quand un
cardiologue était pris d'ailleurs un peu
pour un farfelu
en 99 il appelle le professeur ou le
docteur juste puciers professeur chiche
à marseille et qui avait fait le premier
le rapport entre médiator et
valvulopathie
or tout le monde lui est tombé dessus et
c'est ce que j'ai eu en tout cas dans
les parages sg la borne d'incendié etc
il a pu terminer et donc ils sont pas
tous quand même à classer parmi des
spécialistes qui n'ont rien vu il y en a
au moins un qui a vu quelque chose et
qui malheureusement n'a pas été
suffisamment pris au sérieux
monsieur le professeur bergman ce débat
est très important c'est celle que le
coeur du problème et comme comme daniel
on peut que louer ce café irène frachon
on peut regretter qu'on l'ait pas fait
nous plus tôt et on peut
essayer de répartir les responsabilités
mais il est vrai que on retombe dans ce
système de fait de poule en disant ah
mais des neurones l'échiné cardio ou les
cardiologues et les changéens cardiaque
si ça avait été dans les rcp il aura été
évoquée encore pas sûr que tout le monde
dise rcp de tous les médicaments
comprennent frime donc pousse pour que
ça soit dans les rcp dans le résumé du
caractère des produits il faut des
bilans corps dont il eût fallu qu'à la
suite de par exemple le rapport du dr
chiche
le système se met en marche et c'est ça
ce qu'on peut les alors pourquoi ce qui
s'est pas mis en marche ou pourquoi il
s'était marié en mars qui s'est mis en
marche tardive ou alors il ya toute une
série de raisons j'étais la semaine
dernière au congrès de la société
française de pharmaco et thérapeutiques
et pharmacovigilance et d'y aller par
les laboratoires aussi non là je crois
que pour grenoble c'était grenoble oui
j'ai payé mon billet de train même pas
vous voyez oui mais c'est pas normal
c'est pas normal
il y avait au moins 80 poster ou
présentation de trois essais
indésirables de telle nature avec tel
produit
quand vous lisez un numéro de prescrire
aux que je lis avec attention tous les
mois et auxquelles j'ai participé à la
rédaction pendant des années des
médiateurs et pourquoi vous ne le fait
plus pour qu'on ne participait plus à la
d'action parce que le jour j'étais
maître de conférences des universités
j'ai été jetée non et oui mais j'aime
beaucoup prescrire néanmoins vous savez
on peut jeter mais quand même donc oui
donc quand vous lisez prescrire des
médiateurs like y en a 40 par numéro de
prescrire dans tout le problème vous ne
gérez la cause non non je n'exagère pas
j'ai compté écoutez moi je lis aussi
prescrire
vous mais enfin j'essaie dans la partie
qui a réservé juste leur vigilance car
l'appât 40 dans le numéro de janvier qui
était le bilan de l'année il y en avait
au moins 15 ah bon alors il faut que je
puisse donc de ma double m le grand
problème c'est la hiérarchisation c'est
la priorisation on ne peut pas la face
ne veut pas les centres de
pharmacovigilance ne peuvent pas tout
gérer
donc là où on a manqué de curiosité
intellectuelle on a manqué de finesse on
n'a pas manqué de de génie scientifique
que sais-je c'est justement d'arriver à
faire la part dans tous ces posters dans
tous ses numéros de prescrire pour
sélectionner le gros gibier et après
donc d'abord on n'a pas bien sectionné
et après une fois qu'on a c'est si on
avait sélectionné valvulopathie et
médiator il aurait fallu se donner des
moyens spécifiques prospectif que ne
sont pas les la notification spontanée
parce que on sait très bien qu'à
notifications spontanées 26000
notification par an pour deux cent mille
médecins ça fait en moyenne une
notification par médecin tous les dix
ans or on voit 10 effets indésirables
par jour par semaine donc on en en ans
déclare pas donc il eût fallu se donner
des moyens spécifiques et prospectif
adapté c'est à dire en fait ce faire ce
qu'on peut faire maintenant depuis peu
le couplage entre les diagnostics du
pmsi et les consommations couplage entre
une structure hospitalière le pmsi les
études farnaud et pharmaco
épidémiologiques
mais attendez il faut coupler des
informations qu à l hôpital
oui mais si avec 5 une consommation de
la nation à la cnam et la cnam elle a
mis beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de temps
à accepter éventuellement peut-être
ligne c'est aussi pour la mortalité
oui mais alors il est oui oui c'est
complet parce que normalement la
dernière aussi des déclarations
deux décès sont anonymes donc c'est très
difficile tout le monde
la cnam a mis un peu de mal de mauvaise
volonté ou en tout cas de lenteur a
donné ses informations de consommation
et de penser qu'un changea cardiaque
père dévale toute la journée va demander
spontanément est-ce que vous avez pris
du médiator il ya trois ou quatre ans
donc il faut il faut il faut que le
système s'allume et il sait pas allumé
et qu'en plus vous mettez derrière ça un
labo qui fait tout pour freiner et quand
les servives freiner ils savent très
bien freiné ils sont très très fort à
celle à vous parler vous étiez admiratif
moi je suis surtout admiratif de leurs
compétences pour freiner les choses que
pour les faire avancer
mais oui mais quand vous parlez vous
avez vu gérald simoneau il vous
racontera que la sphère isoméride encore
auditionner bon bah il vouera la halle
en fonction de l'audition à
l'international que j'ai visionné il
vous raconterai que quand il sait quand
il est parti dans dans la croisade
isoméride ça a duré trois ans et moi
j'ai eu rennes frachon avant les
réunions en a et même et je lui ai dit
attention ça va ça va durer trois ans et
j'ai été très étonné franchement de voir
comment servier a lâché l affaire si
vite alors que s'il avait fait comme
comme isoméride on serait encore en
procédure appel conciliation cassation
et compagnie s'ils ont vraiment lâché si
vite c'est vraiment bas ils ont admis
l'évidence et je suis content et étonné
qu'il ait admis si vite parce que avec
l'isoméride
ils ont mis trois ans à lâcher le
morceau un ouais enfin sur le plan
juridique parce que l'isoméride a été
retiré du marché quelques deux jours
après qu'il était aux états unis il n'y
a pas eu de le médiator ce qui m'a
étonné c'est que quand l'étude frachon
est sorti à trois mois après c'était le
médiator était retiré hills aurait pu
être beaucoup plus long donc là je pense
80 pour la se féliciter de weeds pas
pour tous mais là oui oui ça a été
rapide pour la fois essayer de faire
comprendre aux français dans la période
entre les médecins ce qui a été ce qui
n'a pas été rapide ce qui a été lent ce
qui a été mauvais c'est la période 97
mais dans la période heureuse mais
tardive où il ya eu les données de irène
frachon les données réguler été données
de la cnam
alors là effectivement le système à
travailler si on a vu de l'état revigoré
oui tout à fait tout à fait on aurait dû
faire ses études plus tôt mais là encore
le système était lent le système n'était
pas hier archi dans le système était
empêtré dans sa danse a dans ses
habitudes et dans ces structures est on
est on est pas là pour pour le défendre
et est tout à fait et le laboratoire
servier a mis de la mauvaise volonté à
mon avis de façon évidente sur ces
dossiers comme ils le font sur d'autres
îles laboratoires servier dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est une
exception qui confirme la règle ou bien
alors est ce que il ya des laboratoires
qui lui ressemble qui sont aussi
procédurier qui voyez c'est parce que on
a eu tendance à dire oui servier sait
c'est vraiment pas laboratoire correct
il a des méthodes et cetera est-ce que
ça correspond à la réalité est ce que
vous ressentez les mêmes difficultés
je suis quand même 25 ans herman oui ya
dans mon cas c'est pas là c'est pas de
groupes c'est linéaire mais servier
c'est quand même le summum c'est le
sommet avait rien bon bah écoutez là
c'est l'avis de l'expert c'est le cas de
le dire puisque
qui a de l'expérience des amateurs et
puis si vous n'êtes pas rémunéré madame
le rapporteur vous continuez de
génériques qui ont été mis sur le marché
en 2009 deux mois avant sa suspension
voire la suppression immédiate heures
pourquoi parce que la procédure est
enclenchée à ce moment là mais les
dossiers des génériques le pouvoir là
aussi la commission d'ayem est assez
limitée à partir du moment où ils
bioéquivalence il y avait bioéquivalence
il suit son parcours de médicaments
génériques
ce qui se passait pour le princeps parce
c'était notre préoccupation porte
essentiellement sur princeps et oui mais
y'a quoi pour mettre des génériques si
on doit suspens d'autant plus que
c'était très peu de nord la décision de
suspendre mais comme l'a dit jean
françois les choses les mêmes qui
décident pour les comme les génériques
comme l'a dit quand il a dit
jean-françois les choses se sont
précipitées en fin de parcours et donc
la préoccupation pour nous c'était la
suspension de la mm de médiator et
l'histoire des génériques combat c'est
arrivé au même moment c'est tout oui
parce que j'ai un mois près non vous
avez quand même un doute
alors quand on a un doute par rapport à
un médicament
on doit quand même pas mettre sur le
marché ou tout au moins différer à la
mise sur le marché du générique tant
qu'on n'a pas levé le doute
et quand les rédacteurs enfin quand le
rapport de la chef de la chaîne voulez
vous attendez indique que le doute
profite toujours aux laboratoires et
jamais aux patients vous avoir et qu'on
a là les illustrations
vous voulez vous venez nous faire dire
que les médicaments qui parfois nous
inquiète nous interpelle et y en a un
certain nombre pour lequel il ya des
questions quand même de le rapport
bénéfice/risque eux et qu'ils sont
génériques et nous aurions europe au
prétexte qu'ils peuvent représenter
éventuellement un risque c'est à partir
du moment où il ya vu équivalence il ya
lieu équivalence il ya bien eu un peu
quand même surseoir surseoir à statuer
dans la tente de la décision définitive
concernant le princeps ça me paraît
quand même c'est vrai que la décision et
la peur du contentieux vous conduit même
jusqu'à jusqu'à ne pas prendre de telles
mesures
vous avez peur que le laboratoire veut
poursuivre si jamais vous suspendez
pendant un an par exemple la mise sur
lâcher du générique dans la mesure où
vous avez un doute sur le princeps
ça paraît quand même assez dafri lose it
et là c'est vrai qu'à décision dans sa
lisibilité
rétrospectivement away sa chance et pas
de raison n'en est pas fière et il n'y a
rien à dire de ce côté là mais là encore
comment sera plus non mais vous rendez
pas compte que le groupe générique et
tous les quinze jours il y lâche pas il
peut avoir 30 40 70 générique un
générique c'est un produit qui est
inscrit originaire et génériques etc a
failli des études de bioéquivalence qui
montre que hill et entre 08 et 125 du
produit princesse pour le type il fait
ça comme il arrive vive et génériques et
et on ne peut pas demander à des experts
qui ont des ddt des problèmes de
positionnement des médicaments et
stratégies thérapeutiques de refaire le
boulot du groupe générique adiba ce
médicament il est un générique boom
alors c'est vrai que rétrospectivement
ça fait tâche on peut pas dire autrement
mais c'est tout tout tout le problème de
ces machines technico réglementaire
par exemple peut-être que c'est la même
chose à laquelle on pense typiquement
prenez l'exemple du roaccutane qui est
un médicament qui a un profil de
tolérance qui interpellent et qui à
l'heure actuelle n'est plus que
générique et puisque les princesses ne
sont plus sur le marché et les femmes à
coller les système de pharmacovigilance
des laboratoires génériques ne sont pas
aussi opérant que ceux des princeps et
donc le gros problème du générique la
société a voulu que les génériques -
percement je suis pas favorable mais
pourquoi le procès ce n'est plus sur le
marché
pas parce que le nombre de génériques
pour lequel au bout d'un moment
l'industriel celui-là vernon sujet il ne
resterait plus que générique et donc
autant une pharmacovigilance et opérante
je ne veux pas dire que tous les
industriels je fais attention à ce que j
surtout qu'on est filmée mais je ne suis
pas totalement sûr que les industriels
du générique ont une politique de
pharmacovigilance qui soit aussi
opérante que celle les princeps
donc ça au moins six disons la loi
pouvait là dessus nous garantir des des
choses ce serait certainement important
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il ya
déséquilibre entre revient sur la
question que j'ai posée un petit peu
tout à l'heure autrement entre les
autorisations et les retraités mis sur
le marché puisque si la mêmes se fonde
sur un rapport bénéfice/risque préjugé
favorable le retrait résulte d'un
rapport démontre est défavorable et si
les études des mêmes sont
populationnelle les retraits se fonde
sur l'étude de cas individuels c'est
qu'elle est en plus difficiles à
rassembler et à démontrer
est ce qu'il n'ya pas
un déséquilibre dû à cela finalement
entre les autorisations et et retrait
demi sur le marché le retrait clés liés
à l'émergence d'un effet indésirable par
exemple n'est pas forcément liée aux cas
individuels il peut être résultat aussi
d'une étude tous les industriels ne sont
quand même pas malgré tout à man
certains industriels font leur travail
des études fasse trop de phase iv avait
existé et qui tout d'un coup vont
montrer qu'après tout le rapport
bénéfice risque que l'industrie elle
croyait vouloir démontrer comme
favorable n'est plus favorable et à ce
moment là il peut y avoir un retrait
soit certaines indications soient là et
même en elle même donc il ya deux
aspects il ya soit l'aspect collectif
d'une étude soit l'aspect individuel
c'est les deux ce que voulait dire
fashola important c'est que quand on met
un médicament sur le marché le 10 sont
là le fait que la balance bénéfices
bénéfices riz bénéfice risque soit
favorable près c'est simplement une
présomption
on n'en est pas sûr que ce rebelle man
l'a indiqué indiqué très clairement dans
certaines de ses interventions dans la
presse mais que mais qu'en revanche et
ça c'est plus monsieur le professeur en
perte même qui parle en revanche
lorsqu'il s'agit de retirer un
médicament
on ne se font plus sur un risque présumé
mais sur un risque avéré un ver est donc
voyez dans un cas il ya présomption et
dans l'autre il faut que ce soit avéré
c'est ça je pense que c'est ça les amis
voilà et dérives marquer si on avait une
autre parce que moi c'est une question
qui m'interpelle ça nous a été
nommé en tout cas notamment dans la
sphère du vioxx est-ce que cela provient
pas aussi du fait que lorsqu'un
médicament sur le mais mis sur le marché
il est mis en place à partir d'une norme
qui est une norme sur pasteurienne bien
sûr alors que lorsqu'il va être mise en
distribution effectivement il était là
il n'est pas adapté à la peau à la
taille il est en général mis sur le
marché pour une population que les
maladies chroniques je vous donnais il
ya dysfonctionnement de la norme par
rapport est donc systématiquement il va
procurer des effets désir est entendue
je vous donnais mon ce tueur je donne
mon sentiment pivot lorsqu'on donne une
mm le rapport bénéfices risques est jugé
favorable
sinon donnerait pas là et même les jugés
favorables il résulte bas présumés au
juge et il est jugé favorable de notre
responsabilité on a considéré que le
rapport bénéfice risque défavorable
cette décision ou cette proposition de
décision elle résulte des études qui ont
été faits dans une population spécifique
c'est évident que dans la vraie vie les
choses sont différentes
certains industriels c'est l'observation
que je fais en tout cas on a un certain
talent pour faire des études dans des
populations qui ne vont pas correspondre
exactement la vraie vie parce que
parfois je suis admiratif et oui mais
c'est le constat qu'on fait vous êtes
admiratif qui ont fait des constats ont
fait les constats malheureusement et
bien entendu alors au jour d'aujourd'hui
on inventer quelque chose qui est allé
plat qui s'appelle plan de gestion de
risque en disant justement il faudra
affiner pour que dans la population
réelle ce qui sera le cadre de la
prescription on puisse vraiment mieux
évaluer ce rapport bénéfice risque donc
vous avez à ce moment là les études qui
sont demandés à l'industriel savez au
jour d'aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup des
plans de gestion de risque qui sont nés
il ya huit 8 ans à peu près 7 8 ans moi
je le dis moi je le dis il faudra à un
moment faire le bilan de ces plans de
gestion de risques pour lequel on va se
rendre compte que les industriels ont
bien fait leur boulot et puis d'autres
les études seront pas forcément au
rendez vous avec l'argument qu'on nous
dira que c'est compliqué à faire c'est
difficile que ceux ci que cela le pilote
réellement c'est que
c'est aussi un autre élément que je
trouve qu'il est très important en
matière de médicaments
c'est que la pathologie peut changer et
qu'à un moment il peut y avoir une perte
de chance et pas seulement les risques
disons du nouveau médicament une perte
de chance qui peut qui peut se profiler
comme donc un médicament en fait il a
une vie de toute façon il a une vie nous
nous sommes là simplement pour donner
des messages alerte a été donnée s'était
dit en 2000 au laboratoire servier de
faire les études avec un contrôle
échographique si elle avait été faite en
temps et en heure on aurait pu statuer
différemment donc vous n'avez si
l'industriel ne fait pas les études et
ben vous avez qu'individuel après façon
les bien obligés à un moment de tirer
une conclusion mais on est dans cette
situation
pour aller plus loin et peut-être
malheureusement même augmenter votre
admiration pour les industriels ils sont
en train d'essayer d'obtenir ce qu'on
appelle les mêmes conditionnelle c'est à
dire ils disent il ya des situations on
aimerait même avoir les mêmes sous
condition avant même que nos études
soient terminées et il les a tellement
les actes et us et se déploie
utilisation c'est avant la décision de
fait déjà un progrès ils veulent encore
mieux qu'ils veulent encore mieux ils
veulent des ae même conditionnelle il
n'est pas exclu qu'il n'ait d obtenir au
niveau européen dont vous faut actionner
vos collègues dans un problème de deux
dessinateurs ratio nation le chat faut
quand même leur dire non
la france d un des 27 pays
c'est bon alors ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'on aura des ae même sous
condition que telle étude qui est en
cours se finisse et soit positive et
soit positive et on va se retrouver dans
une situation quelque est la même que
celle qui génère s'éprendre gestion
risquons on engrange de l'information
puisque effectivement la population dont
le la vie réelle n'est pas la même que
la police y ont bien choisi des essais
cliniques des malades très particulier
où les informations harry est hélas vous
pourquoi est-ce que à ce moment là vous
retirer pas là et même n'oublions pas
que si on a trois quatre effets
indésirables sur un mal à un médicament
qui est donnée à 35 mille malades
il ya aussi 34 1997 patients qui
prennent le médicament
et un certain nombre d'entre eux en tire
bénéfice est de dire ah bah voilà il ya
trois malades qui sont morts donc on le
retire qu'est ce que vous faites des
autres je vais vous raconter l'histoire
du natalizumab le natalizumab un
anticorps monoclonal qui est des nains
dans la sclérose en plaques
il a été développé encore le
développement s'est aperçu que dans les
essais cliniques
il y avait trois malades qui avaient
fait sous natalizumab une le conte ses
falaises multifocale progressive
l'aiment pas une maladie qui est si de
la connaissent bien
mortel bon quand j'ai lu le papier dans
le new england sur l'aim avec le
natalizumab je me suis dit ce médicament
il est fini et il est mort on va pas
mettre sur le marché un médicament qui
tue bon et bien paradoxalement malgré
les trois cas de leyme les associations
de malades atteints de la sclérose en
plaques ont dit oui mais nous on a vu
que ce produit il donnait 20 % de
réponses et à 20% des malades qui
s'améliore dans la sclérose en plaques
et nous on pense que on préfère 20 % de
réponses avec un cas sur cinq cent de
leurs discussions ont dit non finalement
pression on s'aperçoit que l'incidence
de l'alem est de 1 pour mille
donc on dit allez un pour mille c'est
prenable c'est ça le bénéfice risque hop
on donne on met le médicament sur le
marché avec un plan de gestion risque
deux ans plus tard on s'aperçoit que
l'incidence ne provoque pas de un pour
mille mais plutôt de 1 sur 2 150 donc
peut-être que on va dire ce qu'on a
accepté pour un pour mille au niveau
européen on va leur fusée pour 1 3 250
c'est extrêmement difficile moi
j'aimerais bien vous demandez à vous
selon que vous soyez médecins selon vous
soyez sénateurs selon vous soyez à la
mmq hongroise hollandaise ou française
selon vous ayez un enfant qui est une
sclérose en plaques selon que vous ayez
un conjoint qui a une l'aiment tout ça
rentre en jeu moi je ne sais pas quelle
est la bonne décision c'est vachement
difficile
dans le jeu le professeur si vous vous
dites qu'on ne savait pas là qui sait
alors baisse passée le groupe perd parce
qu'il faut il faut ce dossier d'une ati
m'a par exemple va revenir par une autre
porte et à la prochaine commission d'amm
m ou celle d'après je ne sais plus très
bien
j'ai demandé et obtenu que les
associations de patients puissent être
présentes non pas pour nous aider donc
la paroisse est permanente de façon
exceptionnelle
écoutez j'ouvre une porte ou c'est moi
j'ai l'habitude de décide d'entre eux
bayer les portes à comment voilà je ne
sais pas si elles accepteront de venir
parce que c'est les sujets difficiles
mais au moins pour recueillir leurs
sentiments
simplement pour recueillir leurs
sentiments peuvent pas pour prendre la
décision parce que je trouve que c'est
pas bien
j'ai toujours fait en sorte et je le dis
pour l'association de patients infectés
par le vih je ne pense pas que ce soit
bien qu'elles soient acteurs de la m
mais qu'elles soient au courant des
choses et qu'elle nous aide à prendre
des décisions et une chose importante
le problème c'est effectivement définir
les populations qui sont qu une maturité
suffisante et je pense que dans le
domaine de la sclérose en plaques il ya
des associations qui sont représentatifs
et on a besoin d'elle on a besoin aussi
à la mm on n'est pas que des experts
dans notre tour pleyel entre guillemets
et passionnant que ça d'ailleurs aimé
cet anticorps monoclonal avait reçu un
smr combien qu'elles ont brûlé je
calculais une et sa mère trois ou quatre
parce que il a été testé chez des
malades c'était rose en plaques
résistant à l'interféron donc en
deuxième les autres questions mais parce
que je ne suis pas très au clair là
dessus
elle n'était pas de mise en ce qui
concerne les dispositifs médicaux un
navet
vous allez compétences non non non non
nous sommes consultés et éventuellement
si le dispositif médical porte un
médicament type stent par exemple qui
porte un produit quelconque
éventuellement nous pose pas toujours
éventuellement nous pose la question
mais on n'est pas dupe c'est donc se
répéter avant mes ptis qui concerne les
produits techniques innovants est ce que
vous avez compétences aussi donc pas du
tout il échappe donc à tout dispositif
les produits techniques innovants sont
utilisés voyez sur le parc à des
commissions et une commission c'est vrai
que le niveau de preuve le niveau
d'évaluation d'un dispositif est
infiniment plus bas que celui d'un
médicament
c'est ainsi que ce les produits
techniques innovants parce qu'il n'y a
pas d' essai contrôlé randomisé ce qui
est autre chose
donc c'est un d'autant qu'il pourra
servir de comparateurs dans les essais
thérapeutiques
bah oui on que c'est une vraie diva
sujet justement à propos des
comparateurs qu'est ce que vous pensez
de la systématisation des essais
comparatifs prêt à mêmes est-ce que vous
avez une opinion un avis sur ce sont ils
sont systématiques il son système à
distance systématique la discussion est
de savoir si le comparateur est un
placebo si c'est un compagnon relative
non mais effectivement il n'ya pas
longtemps et même ça je vous rassure
jean françois est ce que je viens
globalement pas des mêmes ne considérait
pas que le le comment laisser versus
placebo était et était à l'essai
comparatif il était bien évident que je
parlais d'un essai avec un comparateur
oui il s'est globalement la règle il ya
qu un seul secteur où il n'y a pas d'
essai comparatif de temps en temps et on
peut octroyer une mm sur une étude
ouverte c'est dans les maladies
orphelines ou parfois de toute façon il
est impossible de faire un essai
comparateur des comparateurs il n'est
pas possible de faire des essais à des
situations de maladies orphelines
paratyphi ne concerne que mettant dix
patients par an en france par exemple
pour qui est impossible de faire un
essai randomisé concernant les essais
versus des comparateurs actifs oui c'est
ça si j'ai bien compris votre question
oui pourquoi est-ce-que pourquoi parfois
il n'y en a pas alors il ya plusieurs
raisons
parfois il n'y a pas de comparateurs
efficace et sans exclure mais où on est
en 3e ligne dans une situation où la
basse thérapeutique mais aussi
malheureusement ça s'est un petit peu
délicat mais mais assez assez précis
quand même malheureusement quand un
nouvel industriels développent un
nouveau médicament dans une casse où il
y en a déjà est connu on se désole en
dur encore à bêtabloquants encore un
truc qu'on a déjà vu à chaque fois il
espère peut-être avec crédulité mais il
espère que son nouveau à lui sera
meilleur que les autres et souvent on
est déçu donc qu'est ce qui peut faire
il peut faire une étude versus un
comparateur qui au mieux est un essai
qu'on appelle un essai de
non-infériorité pour montrer que le
nouveau n'est pas moins bien que ce qui
existe déjà ce qui est la moindre des
choses mais ne montre pas pour autant
qu'il est mieux
oui eh bien ces essais de de
non-infériorité pour des raisons
méthodologiques sont extrêmement faciles
à biaiser cd et c'est fragile en terme
de méthodologie
donc on leur demande des essais de
non-infériorité qui font par déception
mais qui ne sont pas forcément la
garantie de l'absolu non-infériorité on
peut dans un essai être avoir l'air
d'être non inférieure sans pour cela
être absolument convaincu que ce nouveau
médicament
ne sera pas peut-être un petit peu moins
bien et puis derrière votre question il
ya est-ce qu'on aurait besoin dans des
arts jrgn d'arsenal avec des trucs qui
n'apporte rien de plus puisqu'ils sont
au mieux d'un inférieur et là la réponse
c'est que d'une part l'industriel au
départ il espère être mieux et d'autre
part on est dans une économie libérale
où on allait droit de développer un 24e
bêtabloquants s'il y en a déjà 23 sur le
mettre en marché et nous n'avons pas le
droit alors qu'on admet tous les jours
des génériques de bêtabloquants
d'interdire avat un 24e bêtabloquants
dès lors qu'il a montré qu'il est aussi
efficace que les 23 premiers n'est pas
lui demander d'être plus efficace ben ça
c'est à vous de nous dire si vous
législateur vous décidez que on ne donne
là mêmes qu'à des médicaments qui sont
mieux que ce qui existe déjà
où on sera l'appliquer jamais vous ne
prendrai cette décision parce que c'est
celle à mandeure braila prenez là nous
intéresse c'est la mort de cette
patiente est vrai sur la recherche c'est
la mort de l'industrie c'est là c'est
comme si vous aimez la rechercher coûte
et on s'aperçoit et à mon grand
étonnement d'ailleurs que de plus en
plus de laboratoires se séparent de
leurs centres de recherche
donc j'ai l'impression que c'est un
secteur qu'ils sont en train
d'abandonner transféré abbott a fermé
son centre en dans les blocs terre oui
c'est ce qui vous est alors c'est qu'ils
ont fait un centre en russie c'est mon
club coûte moins cher oui oui mais enfin
je sais pas si si c'est le cas en
l'occurrence les 6
toujours est il que on a l'impression
que les les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
n'investissent pas dans la recherche
autant que par exemple dans le marketing
et lorsque j'aurai tessa toujours oui
mais ça ne veut pas dire pour autant que
pas bien votre show non mais quand on
est on est on aimerait que si on met pas
des médicaments inefficaces sur le
marché ou pas plus efficace que ce qui
existe déjà au tu la recherche et je
signe que ce les finlandais
l'arraisonnement qui auquel j'ai des
difficultés à adhérer
parce que si j'ai besoin de médicaments
c'est pas tant pour faire vivre
la recherche c'est surtout pour apporter
un bénéfice aux patients mais dans la
mesure où ces océans n'apportent pas de
bénéfice
eh bien je crois que il faut
effectivement il ne faut pas pour autant
abandonné la recherche et ne plus
financer la recherche mais faut
peut-être trouvé d'autre moyen de
financer la recherche
mais mais si on compare l'âge d'or des
années 80 on a trouvé beaucoup de choses
des enzymes dans une conversion les
antirétroviraux tout ça bon tout le
monde rêve où les malades les médecins
et bien sûr aussi des industriels de
trouver des nouveaux médicaments plus
efficaces et nous notre bonheur serait
d'avoir que des bella et même pour des
nouveaux produits et d'avoir que des à
smr 1 2 ou 3 tout le monde serait
heureux de ça et mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait si si c'est pas le cas
qu'est ce qu'on fait si l'industriel
essaye développe et puis paf laisser
arrive et c'est au lieu de montrer la
supériorité ils montent à mieux la
non-infériorité est ce qu'on lui dit
bombe à rentrer chez vous vous avez
investi 2 milliards
votre truc il est pas moins bien mais
n'est pas mieux on le met pas sur le
marché
si vous le décidez c'est facile à
appliquer la finlande a fait ça dans les
années 75 85 de plus un seul labo qui a
développé quoi que ce soit en finlande
oui mais il est y est ils ont quand même
et la toile en aidant l'europe
maintenant il avait un vidal de poche
oui c'est au moins depuis mai donc vous
vous considérez un puisque ces
médicaments que vous mettez sur le
marché sont automatiquement jusqu'à
présent remboursé par la sécurité
sociale
donc ce qui veut dire que par voie à
diac c'est là c'est l'assurance maladie
qui finance la recherche par le canal de
ces médicaments vous mettez sur le
marché uniquement pour pour que
l'industrie pharmaceutique puisse
continuer à faire de la recherche veut
bien mais aussi à se développer et à
faire en sorte que la rémunération des
actionnaires soient toujours ce qu'elles
aient quoi parce que jusqu'à présent la
nôtre et cherche à ce titre fait partie
de notre économie libérale on n'a pas
décidé qu'en france et d'ailleurs sont
décidées en france sans le décider dans
le reste de l'europe ou a fortiori du
monde ce serait forcément punitifs et
contreproductif on n'a pas décidé
d'administrer la recherche de du
médicament en france
si demain on décide que la recherche
dans le domaine thérapeutique est une
fonction de l'inserm et du cnrs etc ont
interdit les industriels de développer
bas ils arrêteront ils seront développés
ailleurs il faut pas oublier que 65 % de
l'industrie du médicament est entre les
mains des américains des suisses et des
japonais il ya peu de chances que ces
trois pays souscrivent à cette décision
donc la recherche sur le médicament va
continuer à se faire dans un esprit
qu'on critique mais qui est quand même
l'esprit aujourd'hui de l'économie
libérale et mais monsieur professeur
vous avez constaté que moi que les
laboratoires cherchent c'est vrai et que
ils trouvent de moins en mois vous êtes
bien d'accord donc on continue à mettre
sur le marché des médicaments inutiles
simplement pour fêter ça il renchéri le
rias sont pas identiques on pourrait
éviter qu'on pourrait éviter tout y en a
un certain nombre qui la porte ne sais
pas plus que ce qui est oui déjà regardé
les premiers y en a aussi qui sont ce
que si nécessaire c'est mais quand vous
commencez votre recherche sur un nouveau
médicament sur une nouvelle classe où
vous espérez mais vous savez pas ce que
ça va donner sinon vous sauriez pas
d'essai bien sûr et des peuples dans
n'importe quelle industrie ont fait des
recherches
y a pas que dans la division
pharmaceutique pour mettre sur le marché
un produit et quelquefois se produit pas
il ne raconte pas de la part des
consommateurs
respectez un autre point est important
c'est que dans ce monde du médicament il
n'y a pas le choix le plaisir du
consommateur qui a changé de confiture
il se trouve que la confiture nouvelle
et meilleure que la précédente et la
grande difficulté quand vous utilisez un
médicament c'est que vous allez avoir
une impression soit parce que vous êtes
le prescripteur soit pas parce que vous
êtes le malade consommateurs qu'il
pourra être là je vais beaucoup mieux ou
qui pourra être au contraire d'autres
médicaments ne fait rien et cette
impression elle et elle n'a pas de
valeur scientifique si vous avez un
nouveau médicament vous le tester chez
trois de nos malades ils ont tous les
trois des boutons vous avez
définitivement l'arrêter alors que si
les trois premiers malades vous dise au
docteur il est génial ce produit vous
allez y croire alors que finalement
c'est peut-être pas un si bon médicament
que ça et l'absence d'outils de mesure
en permanence de cette efficacité la
crédulité des industries d'aider des
médecins prescripteurs
je suis enseignante thérapeutique est la
crédulité bondi qu'ils sont sous
influence que les laboratoires exerce
une influence sur via les visiteurs et
qu ils sont ils sont entièrement
responsables ils sauront ils sont
co-responsables je suis très responsable
en tant qu'enseignant de thérapeutique
jeu j'essaye de former les futurs
médecins à un bon usage du médicament
je leur forme à la lecture critique
d'article nouvelle épreuve examen
national tassant pour qu'ils aient cet
esprit critique
je fais des cours des visites où
j'essaie d'expliquer mais je suis aimé
danièle aussi et derrière ça il ya le
rouleau compresseur de la visite
médicale du sein peau du du porte clés
du post it et du stylo bille et dans ce
monde là c'est un peu david et goliath
sais c'est clair que le médecin français
là les études marketing le montre bien
est caractérisée par les gens du
marketing comme qu'on appelle un
prescripteur rapide c'est à dire que le
médecin français aiment beaucoup le
médicament moderne
l'apple la vitesse de pénétration d'à
nouveau médicament sur le marché est
sensiblement
élevé en france que dans les pays
nordiques ou disons anglo saxons c'est
de notre responsabilité c'est comme ça
et c'est dommage mais c'est une réalité
bien il est armé je voudrais avant de
partir vous poser une dernière question
à monsieur professeur bergman ses
lectures d'une de ses déclarations dans
dans le monde qui m'a incité à vous
poser une question en tout cas faire une
observation
vous dites je vous cite à je ne sais pas
si c'est en tout cas voilà ce qui est
jean françois bergmann met le doigt sur
le cancer qui ronge l'hôpital public et
jouera surtout dessus totalement
d'accord avec vous
et hélas l'ensemble de la médecine
française le soin des malades est
devenue une industrie qui doit faire du
profit très bien d'où le déluge de
scanner irm des appareils de plus en
plus coûteux il faut les user les
amortir les remplacer leurs fabricants
sont à la porte
dans l'attenté fébrile de nouvelles
commandes et s'est arrêté là
parfaitement la grave ou et dans tout ça
le médicament il réalise des profits
dans les rallyes spa et que ses
blessures sur le même rang que ses
propres se tapper qui fabrique des
scanners et tout ça où est-ce qu'ils
soient pas non non c'est pareil vous les
avez vous parlé alors non mais j'ai
souvent en pointe ou le point d'être
souvent écrit sur le médicament de
professeurs garde ma liens d'intérêt
avec toc aussitôt ça fait mal interprété
vous comprenez on dire ah bon j'ai passé
un hiver mais il garde bien de critiquer
d'abord à tort pourquoi parce qu'il a la
prétention on a entendu pour tous et
encore ce que vous lui demandez vous lui
demander de ne pas s'exprimer à ce prêt
pour une fois que quelqu'un qui
s'exprime dans la presse avec
si vous rendre plus léger je ne fais que
dire que je sais le sénateur si vous
reprenez toutes mes écrits dans le monde
puisque ça c'était dans le monde ça
s'appelait à l'e3 l'hôpital public
là je parlais de l'hôpital public qui
est aussi un employeur très bien très
mais j'ai écrit trois quatre fois des
articles dans le monde 1 sur les
évaluateurs où j'ai essayé d'expliquer
qu'il étions bénévoles et honnête et
plusieurs sur les médicaments y en avait
un qui s'appelait donnant donnant qui
s'appelait je veux bien qu'on nous fasse
enfin la formation médicale continue sur
la thérapeutique mais en échange et
qu'on s'a se paient pour ça parce que
ils veulent casser pour aller faire la
fmc mais en échange de ça il faut que
cette formation soir certifiantes et que
on exige qu'elle soit obligatoire donc
j'ai écrit sur le médicament est est ce
que font les les scanographies cela nous
expliquer que scanner d'avant il est
démodé et je dis toujours que c'est
comme mon fils qui m'explique que la
nintendo 4 elle doit remplacer la 3 et
qui géra pluie jouera plus jamais avec
l'a3 maintenant il ya la cap sur le
marché c'est exactement la même chose
avec les pc j'ai dû ce matin une étude
sur le camp des sarthe en versus le les
sartans inquiet génériques et et l'autre
qu'il est pas bien évidemment
aujourd'hui le médecin il va recevoir
des visiteurs médicaux des produits nom
générique est et il va être par cette
visite médicale par la presse médicale
certaine presse médicale par beaucoup de
choses
inciter à prescrire le plus moderne
c'est à dire celui qui est pas générique
et payer plus cher mais je suis le
premier encore une fois reprenez tous
mes écrits je suis le premier à dénoncer
ce système mais c'est notre système
c'est celui que le législateur a voulu
oui mais il faut effectivement il ya
comme un article dont je me souviens
puisqu'à l'époque
vous avez une mission là encore sur le
vieux que ça c'était dans le figaro
c'était pas dans le monde où vous avez
effectivement défendu le vioxx a alors
là vous avez pas besoin que vous avez
pas eu besoin de le suspendre
c'était dans
je crois que je l'écrivais souviens très
bien
j'écrivais que aujourd'hui on avait
décidé du retrait du vioxx sur le risque
cardiovasculaire sais pas vous ces
laboratoires
hausser de laboratoire carrure est tout
à fait mais on n'avait pas compté la
différence en hémorragie digestive et je
me posais la question de savoir si on
perdait un infarctus ont gagné en
hémorragie digestive on retourne sur
notre problème
oui permanent qu'est celui du bénéfice
risque aujourd'hui en termes médiatiques
de faire un infarctus
c'est un crime d'empêcher une hémorragie
digestive c'est moins grave
donc ce qu'il eût fallu faire est ce que
personne n'a jamais fait sur le vioxx
c'est de mesurer le nombre d'infarctus
induits et le nom d'hémorragies
digestives éviter je n'ai pas fait non
plus et avant de dire il faut retirer le
dieu pourquoi le vioxx a été retiré par
mr c'est que le jour ils ont calculé le
prix que leur coûterait l'indemnisation
d'un infarctus américain pour un malade
qui prenaient du vioxx par rapport aux
bénéfices qui prenait chaque jour en
vendant new york le jour où le prix à
payer c'est mais la fia ce tri ses
bénéfices et les risques on est là moi
je me dis la question qui se pose c'est
combien on induit d'infarctus kong en
est on empêche d'hémorragies digestives
pc
si on avait eu à décider en a et même du
retrait du vioxx on l'aurais pas pris
sur combien ça coûte un procès pour un
infarctus à venir surtout que ça coûte
rien chez nous mais on leur esprit sur
qu'est-ce qu'on gagne qu'est ce qu'on
perd et on revient sur le problème du
bénéfice risque qui aurait impliqué les
données de pharmacovigilance à condition
qu'on les hait qu'elle soit fiable et
les données d'efficacité du produit et
c'est notre notre notre corps de métier
on a les mêmes c'est sans doute pour
cette raison que vous avez mis sur le
marché l'arcoxia et que vous avez
maintenu sur le marché un médicament
dont j'ai oublié le nom voisin du vioxx
l'arcoxia été mis sur le marché sur une
année et même européenne
pour lequel la france est opposée et
finalement ça a été décidé
l'afssaps a utilisé toutes les arguties
possible pour empêcher la mise sur le
marché alors que dans trois ans je crois
que ç'a duré pendant trois ans fait et
c'est la manutention repousser la menace
de sanctions au niveau européen qui fait
que le directeur général a quand même
cédé sur donc je comprend enfin je vous
rassure beaucoup de médecins prescrivent
et le vioxx avec un ip un inhibiteur de
la pompe à protons donc c'était la
ceinture et bretelles c'est à dire que
l'argument que vous évoquez en faveur
des s'était pas leurs recommandations
qu'on a fait n'est pas les médecins
encore une fois non mais en dehors de
l'étude mucosal qui a été fait avec le
milieu postolle il n'y a pas d'études
prouvant que l'adjonction d'un ip paix
avec un anti inflammatoire non
stéroïdien diminue l'incidence des
hémorragies digestives
il y a des études qui montrent ça
diminue les érosions endoscopique les
douleurs mais il n'y a pas de preuve que
l'adjonction d'un limiteur de la pompe à
protons avec un mayennais ce diminue le
nom d'hémorragies digestives
donc c'est c'est une prescription fanta
disons conjuratoire et ça fait partie de
mes refrain d'enseignante thérapeutique
mais là encore malheureusement c'est un
échec de plus écoutez là j'espère que
beaucoup de médecins vous entendre tout
casser souhaite bon il est 13 heures oui
je suis seul donc je pense que qu'on
puisse aller beaucoup plus loin
je vous remercie infiniment de jeu
peut-être à bientôt
c'est la fin de cette audition consacrée
au scandale du médiator si vous
souhaitez la revoir elle est disponible
en vod sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
cet après midi à suivre à partir de 16h
le débat sur la laïcité
journée à tous